[Music]
here you gotta wonder who's letting her
do this and be very know who's watching
because they're so pinged he looks like
he's got like fingers and they're and
stuff like that they look disgusting we
had kids this is what we want more weird
kids sometimes I just like the shore
Lawrence videos freak them out a little
bit well we'll see if you do grizzly man
we did that we're going back to a route
sort of thing not people who what I
would not asking for death the way he
did well may be tempting a few people to
come and kill them ribs you know how I
like air some are yeah for those who
don't know yes mo I already want out
ASMR is when when mainly women the thing
is for me personally a woman talking
quietly relaxes me it's a rarity mostly
when women talk to me I get anxiety I
feel a bit on edge right whereas when
these you don't know how to be around
them well when the insecure no not
really
oh and these girls do it they do it
Saudis it relaxes me and it's something
to be celebrated it's a rarity women
speaking quietly a rarity right so I
just want people to say sort of if they
hovered on you cuz you're like the
audience to me yeah I'm sort of taking
you down the rabbit hole right okay
cardi B there are some good ones Oh get
the weird-looking guy yeah I mean he
does look weird doesn't he wow I wasn't
expecting to see him here I was sort of
looking for the hot girls but we'll go
with it hello my name is Madi oh wait
you've revised he needs those eyebrows
done doesn't he bless him I actually
quite like them Yoshio pose I was
thinking they were quite a Mindy really
imagine you're his colleague at work and
you you don't know he does this and then
one day this just pops up in your
recommended this guy normally just does
HR he's sitting in the office and just
going yeah of course I get that typed up
for you and then you see this and he's
saying the same thing
and how are you okay great I need a few
minutes to get my station ready get your
[__] together my East ma canal
you should have had this ready before
you switch the [__] camera off is
this one of those things where he's
pretending we're in the room with him do
you know what I'm thinking though if I'm
stressed out from work the last thing I
want to do was hear about his [__]
have I been dealing with country can't
get their act together all day at work
then why do I want to hear him imagine
if you did your video Majan if we did
the kickoff like this welcome back to
the kickoff on today's show we'll be
watching the football is that something
that's good for you but now you mention
it I really want to start the next show
like he's taking a photograph of the
camera taking a video of him we've gotta
pretend itself we're in Inception oh I
blinked he seems like the type of person
who correct me if I'm wrong would take
all of these photographs of all of these
peoples and then one day you go into his
living room it's a string between them
and all of the bits of string lead back
to him
forget about we talk until I get the
feeling she frames up not for her face
she's cut off a head you have to be and
I'm just gonna put this out there a
little crazy turned on to like I don't
so this is this is the point right so
that you're getting to the similar point
that you know a lot of men get when you
watch this sort of stuff I don't think I
this is where it's a little bit weird
okay so there's a lot of girls who have
been doing this who are like you know
grown women who are a truck and men are
watching them because they're kind of
into it I think I know where this is
going and then unfortunately like it's
just getting a little bit really weird
because kids are now doing it hmm and I
kind of when I watch this I was like I
want to see Lawrence's reaction so I'm
guessing before we start this she's
innocently doing what the adults are
doing thinking she's doing I think
you're on the right lines right but
there's a point where here you've got a
wonder who's letting her do this yeah
and be you've got a wonder who's
watching this apparently a lot of people
what two million people watch this one
subs in the last 30 days 200,000 for
this tragedy you think she may be a
person of smaller a little
yes no I think she's a chooser what I'm
a 12 year old girl 20 going 12 year old
girl who's currently making between
4,000 and $75,000 a month
do you ever this is imagine given her
pocket money imagine what you're gonna
do you're grounded
no she's paying the rent mum yeah dad
can I borrow your car keys why are you
wearing that cop uniform it doesn't
matter why is Missy sitting in the car
in a full police uniform either that a
microphone she's got there she's setting
up a cab
someone's holding the camera mmm who's
holding the cam who's holding the camera
I thought that was on a tripod so not
only they she's got enough mates
involved or a mother because I've had a
pop before about families who do vlogs
and I think it's weird when parents push
their kids in front of the camera to
make money off of them that's so weird
let me tell you something here ASMR yeah
all right okay this is another ASMR
thing I've heard about what wears a lot
of the nail thing that's not relaxing no
none of this is relaxing you just been
pulled over if I thought I'd get a
speeding ticket I'm not like this is
relaxing imagine you've got one any
other day especially from a 12 year old
cop you know they're gonna be petty
you're not it is you know you've been
[__] dumb if a 12 year old can cut
you yeah
again I'll just be very clear this is
now unrealistic if a policeman was made
to wait this long for you to wind the
window down everyone you'd be you'd
either be gone or there be a gun out
angry she's saying roll the window down
repeatedly she's clearly not wearing her
own sunglasses I'm realistic she's gonna
shut up in LA she right got the old one
literally she must have watched her
mother speak to her father like that
many Thai there must be the biggest cut
imagine you're letting your
twelve-year-old daughter I just talk
[__] like this on the Internet
this does not look like a licensed
police vehicle little kids do weird
things oh yeah she's obviously not aware
of what she's doing and probably how it
looks like in in five years she's gonna
wish the rain she never made this and I
understand and I'm talking about the
people around us that's that we are just
talking about she's she's a menace to
society
they often say that I'm an officer of
the LA mm I was expecting please either
me as a total left oh that's it he seems
an innocent little kid but the whole
thing is just so weird let's tell it how
it is all right
whispering and role play two things
commonly associated with sex so this is
weird [__] we're watching this is
normalised wedge it's already weird [__]
yeah and then letting a child do it
makes it even weird
I'm very wrong I think you can do the
whole whispering thing without it being
sexualized yeah absolutely but when you
start dressing up in role-playing I
think this may be the weirdest [__] I've
ever watched on the internet that isn't
like porn related Congrats on the
million congrats though yeah her mother
brought a bottle of vodka
she was just wondering in she literally
she gets into bed at night she goes Greg
we've gotta stop this stuff and he just
goes no let her be who she is seriously
Greg I think it's getting out of hand
now oh god what I keep thinking is is it
like what there's guaranteed to be Peter
so they're just feeding off of this
absolutely like this is soft porn sort
of thing for Peters yeah they're loving
do you know when you say those those TV
shows where the kids are like during
beauty contests and the kids are like
totally but then sometimes the mothers
the pushy one I want to know ways the
driving force here what we need I know
we need to work out who was the boss
when she first started I didn't know
what it was so I googled it I can't
breathe Virgina trying to find out if it
was like an inappropriate thing for
children yeah that's where I first saw
course - is this inappropriate because
she [__] knows it is she went down
the correct track of a good of the wrong
answer this is great parenting so far
you write and then it doesn't make [__]
loads of cash yeah well then hmm that
sound good calm the so now it's just
sounds like a it's bad isn't it Brian's
funeral played this part of the video
Brian changed my life
can I show you something that for a very
long time I think it's my favorite
youtube channel ever but I've never
showed you because of waiting for one of
these this was a kid who was when he was
like 14 15 obviously set up his own
YouTube channel it's a two-and-a-half
minute food review
me [__] the chicken connoisseur this
guy's the real this guy is the real deal
just say he finishes and he goes it's
either a buyer it's not a pie see we are
they gonna buy it or not right this fits
the best bit of the whole video so this
bit okay you this will get stuck in your
head for days ready go food reviewer I
do reviews on the YouTube
you never do such a fool dude I keep it
so flat and do you know why it's because
I know whether to buy their food fades
out of that into you I would never
expect him to be the guy sitting there
at the end of this I love it just be
chicken that does it good onion rings
just wow that's a big bite just another
bite he's not done yet
he's formulating an opinion yeah well I
sleep this every with every bite
Lawrence he's downloading information
using his tongue tongue to brain that's
it yeah it's a land connection Wow
I do love him he's so do you know when
you have the piss in it in the train
toilet and you're like cuz you're really
hot I love him but he's such a nice kid
not bad no pod 3 bytes not bad part of
the reason that I think he is the way
that he is and I'm not making fun of him
for the way is he is overweight and he
acknowledges it and yeah I don't mean
that in a nasty way I'm just when it's
that much of a struggle just to eat of
her go and you're like deep breathing
that deep mr. Chu he's not gonna make
the Wembley Cup team no I was worried
about me he does reviews on the huge he
seems a lot more happy about life there
yeah you can tell this was when he
actually had hoped for this channel this
is 2030 yeah he's young he's vibrant
he's thinking yourself this might go
somewhere it's friendly watching it and
he's trying to articulate everything
he's doing good views there solid views
by the buddies just a man eating in a
car
some [__] like that what is he
preserving the secret fold or is he
thinking one day might have his own
kitchen his last breath the secret dies
with me you can tell he's one of those
over where kids who eats his feelings
bless him and now I see why you like him
I you warm to him the more you watch
normally youtubers are Eagle maniacs and
super confident and when he's the
opposite exactly recipe so secret even
he doesn't know this is why I'm funny
about this video right and that's where
I work out this is why he's overweight
his mom's putting a whole stick of
butter to pancake it stuns me
beautifully clean kitchen oh this porch
literally what has been living in that
kitchen is a natural he's a natural this
is why TV's [__] and YouTube is great
look how much he's melting on I love
where you went with this boom I love
where you went with this damn weird kids
this is what we want more weird kids he
goes boom right it's as if he's joined
by a woman in the kitchen area I can
make a few things Jack I can make a few
beautiful dishes do you know and you
feel a bit non conferment you a tear
near Joanne like no do you feel a bit
[__] about yourself like he is the
antithesis of like how we all feel
inside here's that really jeremy and
he's just eating his feel like i was i
was just like you and you want him to
succeed like i'm watching this thinking
I hope these pancakes are good for you
I'd fall to the as we know this was five
years ago and now is some gum
things I forgot my little you know
[__] go crazy and take it out I'm
[__] crazy
he's taken out a few minutes early he's
[__] crazy he thinks he's getting
sick from not melting the cheese enough
no that's Salmonella from not cooking
the [__] chicken me still go that
looks like he's got like Lucky Charms in
the pancake I think I figured out the
secret genuine sorry man yeah he's just
checking it that's no golden brown
that's black
he's burden is burnt
boom I want to know where his parents
are like if they're if he goes mom just
stay in the living room for a little
while I need to be cooking in the
kitchen or you can have me outside he's
just [__] it I mean jesus [__] christ
but it's it's just thick and lumpy us in
it mm-hmm he's not mixed that well
blueberries this is this is an up sort
of stick look if he was your son you'd
be like what up what are we gonna do
he's made a lot what he's gonna put
butter on it though this is like a bread
stick this is Panda [__] how much how
much love the ring because they're so
pink D looks like you've got like
fingers in there and stuff like that
they look disgusting make no mistake
they are disgusting what a mess that is
oh I had some a little earlier and I
just fell in love can we just see him I
just he said he said he's not a fan of
this let me just say I'm not a fun he's
just what he does when he's a fan of it
he's not a fan of that cerb like I'm not
a fan of [__] like haze all over this
exactly he's actually gonna eat that I
hope so
I really loved this guy's an unsung hero
I ever seen making a murderer like he
could be one of the family
yeah but that's what I like about ya
like the family are so honest and nice
some of them do you know we don't know
the verdict have heavy he wanted them
light and fluffy oh he's a nice he is in
his element he just wowed he's having a
rush wow I feel like this so thick he
needs a drink of milk please bud crayon
you can sell his life he's getting his
ASMR on here I love it this was pre ASMR
because they're so thick there's so much
pancake in him I love about him he's
giving a real serious review of this
like yeah I mean the life is he living
where he's actually thinking about the
ratios of cinnamon just syrup to
pancakes he looks down the
disappointment yeah he'll they're good
that's what I love about him one extreme
to another right there's a guy I see any
other day who's in team 10 that's a
[__] [__] I want to know what you
think of this kid I look through a
couple of videos with it because he
seems to be like a big name but then
what I watch his videos I was like why
why yeah why this is the seen this guy
before I don't understand why but Jake
Paul got him involved in team ten only
people in team ten allowed the two first
names Justin Roberts Jake Paul yes
Michael Michaelson it is strange isn't
it what is up guys so my name is Justin
Roberts and you might have seen me in
cake Paul's blogs lately I've been
hanging around team ten house for about
a week now he's gone for the emotional
music because someone's left him ten
basically he's been there a week no so
he doesn't give a [__] doesn't know
Jenna he doesn't give a [__] he's
probably forced them out some drama that
has been
with chance and Anthony and I just want
to tell you guys my side of the story
your side of the story is you've been
there a week so you don't give a [__]
you don't know these guys make some
pancakes it's really nothing to do with
you one day was like day six it was day
five everything had been five from day
one two three and four four one day it
just it just went all wrong he's making
emotional music as if he's like he's
been in the house three years and it's
all ending for him like you've been
there a week or he's just released a
music video and I wanted to get your
opinion on it right well watch his music
video oh she sneezed he didn't bless her
food this guy is the I don't he's a
young guy so I don't like the people
down he's a kid
you know I mean this is about the young
youtubers coming out Jake Paul wants to
try and create something special with
team ten hmm and I read that idea of
like you know you're gonna find a young
talented and bring them up here I mean
we're trying to do similar things with X
oh yeah this guy is just the most
talentless boring [__] you could ever
meet in your entire life
rhymes though other than the guys got
money why on earth would Jake bring this
kid into the for like I'm just trying to
make them into a star it's not gonna
happen
yeah it's not the ocean Brian not gonna
happen me another verse see if it gets
any belief thrilled to be there the only
good thing about the video is the girls
and even they look [__] sick of their
lives but he's not selling out any
arenas this kid could not sell out an
arena you're talking [__] me you're Jake
Paul's [__] errand boy I understand
not every rap is supposed to be like a
lyrical no but this is just dog [__]
yeah absolute dog sure he eats at Nobu
she asked if she could he said Nobu this
is where YouTube's headed I don't I
really hope so because it's gonna make
our content a lot easier and wake us
look amazing yeah yeah
this is good he's popping us up I should
be thanking them yeah just this is a
message director Justin wrote Justin you
make me look great that's literally the
opposite of eloping so if you're
thinking of eloping you don't go to your
grandma and go thinking of a lump Ingram
of course the gram I was gonna go don't
go the whole point of her lot because
you don't tell your family yeah you
haven't thought this through just yeah
she's not thank you for loping she's
asking if you can leave because you're
surrounded by [__] yeah oh [__] this
conned alright I'm done you know what if
you want to see us watch stuff please
send it in no no sir we're gonna do more
the sort of stuff cuz yeah just fancy
doing a bit of [__] on YouTube I
quite enjoyed watching this to be honest
I think we should have some lunch and
what Tyler cook some lunch okay
let's do that if you have any problems
with anything we've said don't forget to
leave a comment which I won't read
thanks very much for watching I'll see
you later
bye bye
[Music]